then okay hi everyone welcome to another
working meeting about language
completeness and consistency for
language we have
a number of topics today let's see how
many we can get through
all right first up
number forms
right so this is a request from
the weighing team for
up to three new
you know foo form functions for
formatting
integers as a factored form mixed
fractions and repeating decimals um
okay
and so which we have wfrs for those
things yes
uh i don't think so no no no
yes and no we we have some but but
are really not suited for
representations they're really more
suited for doing something
okay
because because like as a representation
if somebody else should eat it how do
you teach the rest to eat it
right well
yes i mean
number form is not eaten by things
right and so i right well my
understanding of the scope of this
request is
uh
that you know it'll behave like number
form so you can still refer to percent
and that will be a number okay
uh yeah i was thinking matrix form is a
good one in my opinion or matrix form
yes
okay
well
maybe maybe as maybe
like if you look at papers about modular
forms and such things it would be nice a
effect of integers if you have a large
polynomial uh would do it with every
indenture not just with the integer in
its own
right what about a rational should it
give you a factorization of the
numerator and denominator i would say no
well hold on maybe this is a form
this is a repeating decimal form right i
mean there's a refusing decimal where it
doesn't look the way that you would like
it to look exactly
like for a vain audience this is not a
useful
form
right it's also no longer the number
it's something totally different
scenario because the d4
output form in vain is traditional form
now you think it's a matrix now it lost
all
relation to what one is used to seeing
right
so i mean
just to give a sense of this i mean if i
do this often alpha
the actual form i'll get is that thing
that involved well what was the
repeating decimal oh under the number
line
oh that's weird i i find it a little bit
weird that the it's beneath the decimal
approximation
in fact
okay
i mean it's weird that's below the
number line that's a bit odd
i mean
it's hard to know what you're looking
for okay so this
we've got two examples here right
fraction
okay
so you want forms that will simply take
so we've already got decimal form right
right
which takes
something like this
what's it doing there
well well it won't do something very
interesting with integers right it'll
right it'll give you that as opposed to
formatting it as a
you know as a float
yep
okay so i just give
whereas
if i give this like this what's it gonna
do
right
okay
so
what you're asking for is something
which for exact numbers
would give point
right and i i it sounded to me like it
would not it would be well at least for
the factored integer case it would be
specifically integers and not also
rationals for
right mixed fractions and repeating
decimals i guess it would take i mean i
guess it's not very interesting with
integers but it would take rationals
yeah
right
and i don't maybe
well i i guess the obvious name is
factored integer form
um
okay
now of course this is the only form we
have
where it might take an astronomical time
to do a computation
no i don't know well actually i think
that's in my form is much more poor
i don't know that's my repeating decimal
because
the periods can quickly get
10 to 10 10 to 100 no doubt but i'm what
i'm saying is i wonder what assumptions
are made in the system about the fact
that
that the form step is not super i mean
like for example the front end probably
freezes
while the form is being generated
not not any more so than it would
any other step right
different from doing the factorization
no no it's it the difference is
for example i've run into this with
layered digraph embedding in graph
theory okay
that it
you know you think you're generating the
graph and then it sits there spinning
its wheel
because it's it's in the rendering
process it's trying to do a combinatory
optimization thing for rendering right
but the front end isn't going to be
rendering right i mean well it'll
eventually render something but it's not
doing the step i mean the problem with
the graph is that it's dynamic and
there's some interplay between
the boxes that are generated and you
know the dynamic rendering here you're
going to the kernel is going to need to
factor this and so it'll just look to
the front end like the kernel is still
evaluating and then the kernel will give
it boxes which are basically
you know the
instead of uh a roblox with lists it'll
be a roblox with some times and some
superscript boxes
yeah okay fine i mean but so you're
proposing that this is what it is and
it's the integer
i don't know why we don't just say
factored form
because then you would expect it to go
for polynomials
should it
the name for the other one should be
mixed fraction form right
that makes factored integer form more
parallel
okay
mixed fraction form
which is to be distinguished from mixed
fraction parts
so mixed fraction form
how long have we had mixed fraction
parts i didn't even know this function
existed
it's fairly recent
two years or something
2019 okay
uh
okay i mean there's probably some corner
cases mixed fraction form when things
get very long and so on and what do we
do
when it breaks the line all that kind of
stuff but i'm sure that can be handled
fairly easily but it cannot get much
worse than
the fraction itself
subtracting integer cannot make anything
worse
right okay fair enough
but the fraction itself goes into slash
form so to speak yeah and and the issue
here is
if this is like 317th
that has to be
yeah what we need is a non-breaking
space character i mean
a space-like character that means
addition i think we have one we do that
it's called implicit plus
okay so that's what it would have in
there
potentially
yep
okay
okay all right so
factored integer form mixed fraction
form and now
what recurring
recurring rational forms repeating is
the most more commonly used
okay but what should it say repeating
rational
like that's all it's for
yeah well this is where i think things
break down a bit right
referring to the decimal what's
do we intend to support it for different
bases
we might as well the like base form
that's why i was that's why i was
backing off from repeating decimal
does decimal forms support other bases
no because it's really only effects in
exact numbers
okay
well i think we definitely need
repeating
like base form repeating
uh
would be real digits form
real
i don't think it needs real i mean i
think
um
is that really reasonable repeating
digits form
the other two cases the middle word
represents the type of the input
yeah i know
so so that would lead to repeated
repeating reflection for
repeated fractional repeating fraction
right but of course it's not the
fraction well yeah it's the
it's the real digits that are repeating
it's just a fraction
i'm just looking various papers talk
still about the repeating decimal form
but using different bases they still
keep the term repeating that's modest
name
are you sure repeating fraction isn't
right
uh i'm sure because uh fraction
right uh there there is a
right base n repeating
form or or term there's a base n
terminal or repeating form if and only
if the the number is irrational right
right
but uh repeating radix
nobody would ever figure it out i know
um i think repeating decimal everybody
would understand even if it was in
another base
yeah
what do people call the digits to the
right of the decimal point in a binary
number
[Music]
[ __ ]
none of it but
they call it the fractional part yeah i
know but what are they called what do
they call the digits
in a binary number other that's just i
guess digits but i mean the okay what
about the decimal point what do they
call the decimal point
[Music]
i never heard it called that
never heard that
r-a-d-i-x
i know how to spell radix sorry
all right he's saying that he's never
heard the decimal point referred to as a
radix wing
radix point of radic's character
according to
this fine place
radix point how weird
oh this doesn't know what it's talking
about i think all right anyway
i i would say that decimal has taken on
an expanded meaning beyond base 10
and similarly for digit yeah
i would agree with that
oh yeah digit of course
depending on what kind of creature you
are all right i think that's fine
repeating decimal form
factored integer form
mixed fraction form now repeated decimal
form
might need to have some kind of option
for its maximum length that it tries to
search for the repeat
or does it not need that
did you understand what i'm saying yeah
yeah i i understand the question i do
not know the answer i um i i don't think
so much for doing the computation but
for the display you might well say the
first 10 the last 10 of the period and
then an indication how long the period
is like dot
five million four hundred seventy
i see that's an elided repeated
so that's like
how would we speak that's like a
precision argument i see so it's the
repeating digits form
so it's the number
and the base
and kind of the um
digits number of digits
but i know i i think i think i think i
think it's more of an option right i
think
right it's like you know above this a
lied above this length
right because the the the period is well
defined yeah
i mean like the equivalent for matrix
form would be
dots vertical
horizontal and diagonal for very big
matrix
which would be nice to have
but we don't even have that for ordinary
numbers other than short basically
in other words
and the new root object stuff
but
what about the new root object stuff
which by the way i hope we have a
meeting to talk about soon you know i
mean the fact that it shows
you know not all the digits you know it
shows an approximation yeah but by the
way we do have that is this an lcc topic
that they're talking about the new
we've already talked about it uh uh
other than the fact that it hasn't been
implemented yet i i don't see what needs
to be talked about again okay i know all
right you see i'm going to keep saying
that until it's implemented because
well you know when you you know
when uh
who's got to implement it
well it's me or or you know if unless
you can make somebody magically appear
but uh
right and it's not as if i'm sitting on
my hands not doing anything
so
well we need to talk about that because
that really does need to get implemented
it's really unbelievably unusable right
now
i
disagree with that statement every
single time every single time
i can't use it
so you know every single time every
single uh and and everything i have not
had an issue with it um have you
actually used it for real yes
okay so what do you do with this i want
to know what are these polynomials
okay
yeah percent input form uh
you know you hover over them
really that's that's the best we can do
i mean i just want to know i want to get
this out i want to copy out the number
how do i do that
copy out the the um i mean you're saying
if i do input form
okay i agree that's perfectly reasonable
what's there but how
i mean i just want to get this thing out
uh first
i mean
uh
does that work or is it atomic i would
have a stomach
and
okay
well i had assumed it was atomic which
probably didn't help
um
okay anyway
all right i okay
okay let's let's go back to this so we
need something which says which is like
a max items
thing
but it's it's a
where else
no i understand but if we want to
generalize that to matrices we might as
well have the same option
i'm i'm not sure that's completely
sensible um
especially if you wanted to combine
matrix form and uh
oh i see
and well no but you'd have different two
different wrappers for that
right but
but you would have but if they both have
the same option one will win over the
other
i think
well i don't think so no it'll just uh
if you have a number form of
if you have a number form of a decimal
form you know they take the same options
whichever one is the inner wrapper yeah
i understand but the point here is that
they're orthogonal things because the
matrix knows that it is being told to a
lied rows and columns whereas the number
knows that it's being told to a light
digits
but but if it's the same option name i
don't see how it
distinguishes between i don't understand
why that's a problem it's going to say
something like
because it'll go up to each tree and see
okay here no i mean it will be like
nesting things that take image size
no but but things that take image size
each one of them will take right takes
it on its own
right
yeah this is what these would do i mean
this one this is max items in
matrix form this is max items in number
form
right but that that's not image there
right that's matrix and
right
um
uh well maybe it's okay but i think okay
but you know it's very strange that
right the the the image size only wind
right
in brad in your example right if each
one of those took an image size
right the image size would only apply to
right that outer image size doesn't
apply to the knob for once i think
you're confused okay i think it's pretty
obvious that this
okay stephen can you do a quick example
yes do panel
of panel
of foo
image size goes to 10 image size goes to
20.
we might need to increase those numbers
but
right and the point is that that outer
panel right that outer image size is the
image size applied to the whole thing
right it it doesn't jump inside a to the
inner panel whereas right that single
number form of matrix form can have a
whole bunch of numbers inside of it
i understand your point i don't think
it's semantically ambiguous
i'm saying because because the max items
is part of number form therefore it's
referring to the number form whereas the
max items here is part of the matrix
form and so it's referring to the matrix
form
[Music]
possibly
okay but in any case
the it's not even obvious we want the
same option for both of them
and why do you guys want to not put not
want to present it like like a precision
option
what do you mean presented like a
precision option well i mean present it
doesn't
like because it's because it doesn't
make sense as an independent thing right
it's
it doesn't it's
the actual value right it only comes
into play if the specific number happens
to be sufficiently long
right
that would just say the maximum number
of digits
right just like precision i mean you
know it would say 10 or something
and that would be the thing that would
determine when it would start a lighting
if it's infinity it never alights
i suppose i guess we normally use these
argument things as sort of cutoffs not
as rated truncates at that point it
doesn't
or it
well certainly in
uh
well in does in in number form it
doesn't in number form it is used merely
to control the display number of digits
uh
well it
it won't write it won't show you
more than that number of digits right
yeah
sorry that won't it doesn't show you
then well that that
right it's not going to show you if it
doesn't have that many well you can't
right no do something more interesting
like
number form of three point four comma
seven
okay
right it doesn't show you
yeah
what's that nor would this
if there aren't that number of digits
it's not going to show you any illusion
but in this case if i said this
whatever it is this you know huge number
of digits here
and let's say i say 20 or something here
that's going to show 20 digits it's
going to truncate right it's it's
truncating that's what i'm saying right
in the other case you need accuracy
you'd say seven comma eight
three
three point four seven command
right i'm just saying it's a bit weird
because right in number form we're
truncating and here we're sort of well i
guess we're truncating from the middle
yeah for just happens to be from the
middle
i think it's directly analogous
and this number this precision number
would be the number of digits you
actually show
[Music]
right after the decimal point i presume
right but are there transients let's see
there aren't there before you hit the
record
oh yeah that's that's uh right so i
guess it's the question yes of the
repeat so it's got an accuracy issue as
well as a precision issue
so something i'm thinking about is that
this is going to be very close to
decimal form itself
and it will require similar number point
various things options and number
decimal form is not doing anything at
the moment on rationale so i wonder
whether
decimal form could be upgraded to do
something rational
i don't think we should i think we
should be repeating decimal form
i think it's a sufficiently bizarrely
different thing
and i think it's going to have a lot of
potential hair to do the way the over
bars are drawn and all kinds of stuff
like this
i think it should be qualitatively
similar
you know n digit precision should be
with n repeating digits and then n comma
f would be
some something which also controls the
number of digits before the before
number of transient digits
but these various options of digit
blocks number signs no we need those we
need to donate
yeah same same as the other function
um all right anything else on these
functions
uh well i guess the question is what's
the priority and and who can we have
work on this
uh i don't know but that's not
particularly for this meeting i mean
this seems like something that should
happen
you know
this insofar as we have an ild operation
this seems like a quintessential ild
type project
so i would recommend somebody in that
orbit
um we can have a look decimal form was
easier because it was directly a form of
number form this will require some
extension
although that code exists i'm often
alpha right
well not not
the code actually
i mean maybe a little bit of that code
but right we're gonna want to do this
and see if we're going to make it into a
proper form
why
because
uh
we want it to behave like a form like
all the other forms
i think that should be i think that's
not obviously correct i i don't know but
but if it's if it's not a form then it
it right there oh it needs to be a form
but i i understand that but the hook to
make it a form let's not get too deep
into these implementation details the
hook to make it a form it's independent
of the actual execution of the function
let's start with danny he wrote decimal
form and i think he can do something
okay
okay
triple at a name for triple h why do we
want this the reason we want this is
because i find myself i find myself
using triple h a lot
um and i just think it's obscure in the
code
and um
i don't even remember what so triple
that
is apply
at level one right yep
as opposed to at level zero right if you
if you
um
that's all i mean i mean this
right if you if you held that first
input and looked at its full form you
would see that it is precisely apply at
level one
okay
so i'm just asking for a
a symbol form of this just like we have
replace repeated in things for slash dot
even though you could get that
by
an argument as you can hear and just you
can't
place repeated is most definitely not
neither replace repeated uh
none of
replace replace replacement
replace apple map or
yeah okay
which i don't use very often i'm afraid
yeah it's kind of a useless function to
be perfectly honest
it's very rare that you want something
to apply to every single
part of yeah i think it's more relevant
if you're doing mathematical
simplification and things like that
where you have a light a function
that you want to just dust things with
um
you know it's very useful if you have a
piece of code that you want to analyze
without any evaluation first you may
pull about everything and then you
slowly take it apart
right
okay fair enough okay yeah
okay look i think map is the obvious
name for this
am i am i confused is that what you
would get if you said
am i confused if i say map
apply
f
onto
now that should be the same thing
yeah
that's what i think it should be called
and that's what multiple other people
have suggested
okay objections
all right do we change the parser to use
this new symbol name or do we
just add this as a new symbol that can i
think it'd be nice to change the parser
but if that turns out to be super hard i
suppose we could point on it i would
prefer to change the parser
it doesn't make
sense
but you you just dropped out we can't
hear you anymore
oh sorry
mike
okay danny we can hear you we can hear
you sighing
am i back
yes
okay
um
where were we with addad at oh um yeah i
think it's been a bit of a problem that
we've had things like divides and and
minus or subtract that
um
parse one way but
have internal semantics that are a bit
different and short circuit i
i think if we're going to call this
uh you'll call this an infix for
map apply it would be nice to parse to
that
okay fine actually you're right you're
right we have had trouble with those
things that don't pass in the most
obvious way
i think um you know we have i think
there's a plan for someone else to get
involved with the plaza so perhaps we
have a good implementation path there
right any objections to this
does it have a third argument or it's
just
no always operates at level one always
level one okay i think so just like
right map always
and and with an operator form right
definitely
definitely the operative form would be
very useful and actually that's one
reason that's one of the many reasons
why i wanted this now that i think about
it
i'm i was going to make a comment about
something here which was
about the analysis
of when one has to put
in hash signs
and when one doesn't have to and whether
there are additional plumbing operations
that you know are similar to i mean i'm
finally the years after we introduced
them i'm steinle is starting to use that
star fairly routinely
um i still don't use
a slash star routinely do other people
here
routinely no
okay but i mean my question is
there are things where i write some
piece of code and then i realize oh my
gosh i've got to put hash signs in here
i can't just have it be
the pure symbolic head
and i have been meaning to try and
analyze when that happens you know what
causes that to happen
the other thing the other very nasty
transition is when i realize i've got
two at signs and i have to name
um you know i have to name the the
function
the
name the arguments
you know what i'm saying
no
okay it depends how many arguments your
function is no no no no you you mean you
mean that you've got a pure function
inside a pure function and so one of
them needs to be an explicit function
instead of a hash ampersand
yup that's what i mean
okay so i mean this and then i say i'm
going to change that to be
this
let's say i want that instead of that to
be
well if it's f of hash
ampersand you know abc that's all good
because it's it's shielded by another
level of ampersand but if i want this
to be i want to make a a this thing i
want to make that
okay i want to say a there
and obviously i could do that with
function a
uh you know blah blah blah here right
but
what i've what's happened is i've got
just hash plus one and then i realize i
need to put in this a thing
but then
actually this is sort of the wrong way
around i mean let's say i've got
you guys get the point
yes you get the point of joining to give
another example no we know the cases
right
so my question is what can we do in
situations like this
is it a user assistance story or is
there something else we could do
well i i'm still not entirely clear on
what problem you're trying to solve okay
i mean
this can always be solved by adding an
explicit function right now right no no
no no there's no problem in actually
writing the code okay okay you know
there's no problem
there is a version of the code that is
absolutely fine no problem
the issue is when you are interactively
composing code
the question is having to go in and
rewrite a piece of code because you were
using hash signs and now you realize oh
you've got two conflicting hash signs
you have to explicitly name the
arguments
a two odd two arc slot
what do you mean
yeah i don't know what that means
like
the the slots from a certain layer work
together oh i see what you're saying
well i don't think that's really going
to help better because i mean in in
unless
i mean we already have look we've taken
the syntax for this
we've taken the syntax for you know hash
two and so on right
the only que the question is
is there any syntax we can imagine
let me let me give you an example
hash signs are like pronouns
okay in english
but you can say
uh
the cat which ate the fish
it you know it was happy no actually
that's a very bad example because that
is precisely an example of what
of of the collision of two hash signs
it's a collision of two pronouns
right
now you know in english for example this
is the famous gendered pronoun story
you know we have this hack with plurals
and genders where we can distinguish
because we have different pronouns
for the plural and the gendered version
right
yes you understand
yes it's it's like saying
his brother and his cousin
you don't know his weather refers to the
original one or the second one no but if
you say
yes right but that's the collision but
if you say
uh
you know
his sister and her
no the boy chased the girl
and she ran fast
then you know
that the she refers to the second
element there right right yep
because you're using that tag
you know you're using that gender
agreement thing there which of course
has been broken in modern times but
that's different story
um the uh but you know that that um
you know that has been the traditional
hack
for essentially doubling in a first
approximation and you know many
languages like french and and you know
italian i think have you know gendered
names for lots of things right in
english it's down to you know i don't
even know and it's even still true that
ships are generally you know female and
you know most objects are it so to speak
but i mean you see what i'm saying
there's there's a there's a hack for
doubling the number of pronouns or
increasing the number of pronouns with
this kind of tagging we do not have that
hack
and that's probably just as well there's
probably no easy way to do it
um
i mean one could imagine a hack where
you go
you know triple hash sign and that
represents i mean this is a hack it's a
bad idea
that represents
a
um
right i mean i think any solution would
involve you going and finding
all of the existing slots and adding the
tag to them which i suppose maybe could
be a user assistance thing but it just
seems no no it definitely needs to be
user assistance thing to the the user
assistance thing should be to replace it
with a named variable
right that you should be able to
transform
a thing that has hash signs in it
to attract to
a
name variable right so so that i should
be able to easily go
hash plus one
um
here right and just say
you know select that actually why not
maybe it just goes in here somehow
select that
i think it goes into the toolbar
yeah okay next menu
but but yes i mean having something
where you select the function and
and you say
and you say give me put a name in here
right yeah that's probably what i want
that's probably what i want but that's
probably the right way to do it
because that's the case where you get
messed up is when you're trying to put
that function inside
and it isn't properly delimited
and then if that can be transformed into
you know the named form that will be
just fine
this is not just hashes right because if
you have various functions and they are
all use the variable x it's the same
program
it's the same problem that's right
so it's it's renamed this rename this
pure function to use
uh
you know and maybe you can also rename
it down
to use just a hash sign
right
i think we'll have to be
smart about what's highlighted versus
not because in in the example below what
you have highlighted it's
it can become unclear if the hash plus f
of hash is
like if you only highlight f of
ampersand
do you want that then to become the
function which i think is what you
originally intended yes right that's
what i intended
which may be different than the
precedence
uh that's correct it might be different
from the precedents now i agree with
that
ethan is suggesting
a notation
like that i mean i think this may get
just utterly obscure
i mean there's
you know a notation that we haven't used
i don't know whether we can whether we
want to use any of these kinds of things
and subscripts
perhaps that's just utterly obscure
i think the toolbar sounds like the
right place for this probably
can we make sure this gets communicated
to the toolbar makers
yes
okay
all right should we should we go on
columns from arrays
yeah um
yeah that's horrendous
and
why doesn't this work
i mean
it seems like it should work
okay well it doesn't work because it was
never implemented
um
right i mean right originally
right when when right when extract
delete
and whoever i'm forgetting at the moment
were introduced right they were
they were designed to eat the output of
position and position would never
produce anything other than lists of
lists of integers
but if i go wait a minute if i go 3
comma 2 here right so that will work
okay
so i can't i have no idea why all comma
three wouldn't work
isn't it consistent to have it work
i i agree that uh it would
uh
um the the the point is again that you
know we need work we need resources yeah
okay okay okay that's not the it's not
our goal in this meeting
but okay well well then tell me
tell me what is the meaning right
because you know i'll see something let
me just try and do design
well for so first
yes but again
we tell me what meeting
uh i need to be at because you know we
keep making all sorts of design
decisions here and one quarter one
quarter of me cannot
implement all of them right right so but
that's not what should be happening i
mean this is presumably something for i
don't know who deals with this rob knapp
or something like that
um i don't know i don't know but it's
not what we i can't help with that it's
not what this meeting can usefully do
well
okay so that's a separate discussion
you know which all right well tell me
where that discussion should take place
uh not here
you could
uh you we can't hear you danny
could throw it
[Applause]
okay we hear you
into ild maybe
that's where it should go i would think
unless it requires some deep core thing
with pac to raise and so on
right i don't know i don't know what the
distribution of resources is for these
things this is not the right meeting to
discuss that
okay
um particularly i agree this is more of
an ild thing
and
you know it certainly doesn't i i would
have thought you would not be my first
choice of a person to implement this a
time not because you couldn't do it
because it just doesn't seem like a good
use of your time right and and and and i
agree with that assessment but right
but
well first of all you know
uh you know the design portion was you
know that do we all agree that this
needs to be done
yes
the answer is yes right and the second
part which is not for this meeting is
who gets to do it and i agree with danny
that is an ild type project
okay
okay but do we all agree that it's a
good idea
yeah i think this is amazing
fine
that's what lcc is about is the design
i was going to say the design of holes
but it isn't it's the design of things
to fill holes yes
it's the locating of holes
right okay
yeah so so this is a bit of a mess uh as
you can tell by the fact that there is
this ginormous table in there which
started with
you know some there were some complaints
from users about uh you know what's
documented and what's not documented
and so with yeah and i have to thank ian
who did a lot of the work here
um of sort of going through all of these
functions and figuring out
what's so if you see nothing in that box
that means it's not implemented
and um
if you do see something that means it's
implemented and sort of the most
visible place where that's actually
documented so for example the fact that
you can do context of the string symbol
to get the context if it exists that's
only documented in an error message
which is you know crazy
um right so so the so there's uh by the
way that's probably the way it's been
for 30 more than 30 years because i
think that's the yeah that's a very old
piece of functionality
right um
and so
um
right so i think there's some uh some
low-hanging fruit um which is
um
let's just ask what we want maybe you're
saying that underneath
right and so i'm saying while i'm saying
things we want and then some more open
questions
um so one thing i would like and
is to sort of completely de-document
the fact that hold pattern of blank
symbol can
be used in
um
attributes and definitions because these
functions are already hold all so okay
can i push back about that for a second
what if you have a list of of symbols
and you want to hold the list of symbols
and you want to map these functions over
that list let's say you want to do a
select
on a list of symbols
now you you're going to say well i could
do that with strings
right
which i think is the much more useful
thing right because then you're not
creating the symbol if you don't have to
i kind of agree with you
i think anybody want to disagree with
this
i'll agree with it and say that i think
options should work with strings
well it it can't because of a very old
design decision where
options of strings means look for the
stream
named
uh
so you can do options on you know stat
out even
um
that's compatibility with a teletype
yeah which of course people still use
um
that's annoying yeah
can we is that functionality we think we
might be able to deprecate or is it
really going to be what will be the
failure case
right well i guess
um
i mean so i guess if we did this
horrifying yeah
right so it's very prominent so i think
if we added support for
a string symbols it would
have to be
you know take happen after we first try
to look up the the stream name but
i i would certainly worry if you try to
yeah and i don't know well but this is
only something
relevant to options on an open stream
right
it's not going to go searching your file
system correct
i wonder whether it works with notebooks
as well on an open notebook
um
i mean if you give it a notebook object
you can get the options of the notebook
object but i don't think on on just a
name it will okay but the stream
would it would be better to have the
stream object there
options of a stream object right
yeah of a yes input stream or output
stream
right so maybe what we should do is a
slow deprecation of this feature maybe
what we should do is start generating a
message
but have it work if there is a stream of
that name have it work
but slowly message that and say you
should use the stream object
[Music]
and then
in the full through case
well i mean
what does it do if the stream object
doesn't exist
uh i believe it gives you an error
message that
can't find a stream by that name
oh no
[Music]
that's just crazy
well i think that's sort of fall through
behavior of like if you give it
uh
a symbol that you know has no options to
find right because any symbol that's
here will already be have been i mean
unless it's in us unless it was in a
string it will already have been created
right
okay that behavior above the options of
a string is crazy
in my opinion
um
i'd like to explore
deprecating that
generating a message in that case
yeah i i i
yeah i mean i would worry a little bit
about backwards i would certainly worry
about backwards i agree but
so we can continue to return that result
but we can generate a message
right
yeah and right i just you know for for
you know completeness if you do options
of you know stat out you'll actually get
the which you could also do as an output
stream right but
you know and and that is something i
know is used in code so that that's and
so maybe we just special case you know
stat out instead air because we know
those are the things which are
those are not i mean the only confusing
thing is if you have a symbol named
stood out
you know who wins
and we could special case those
particular things
great
yeah i mean i think right i think it i
think if we handle stutt out and stutter
and no other streams
that would be ninety nine point nine
nine nine nine nine percent of the
i don't think it is
i would give it four nines at most
but but
and then then we would error we would
generate a message
and then
if there was in fact a symbol by that
name we would go and find the options
for the symbol
if there was a okay the cases are if
there is no some if there's no stream
and no symbol we generate a message
if there is a stream and no symbol we
generate a message but return the result
great
okay let's look at the rest of this
table
okay i mean i
think you are you're wanting to just
remove the whole pattern case
yes
we have why that was introduced
uh is there something that returns hold
pattern
don't think anything returns hold
pattern i mean we do have some precedent
of
i mean obviously besides the pattern
matching functions i think we do have
some pattern uh you know some precedent
of non-hold all functions which
take hold pattern is sort of a
poor man's
you know unevaluated you know
but um
i think i
yeah i don't remember i mean right this
was done a long time ago like in the
version two or version three er era
well i guess it let's see hold pattern
was
i think was new in v2 so maybe that's
when that was done commit messages we
should look at them yeah um
i i think it was not super
[Music]
i i did take a look at the history and i
don't remember finding something
particularly interesting but that
doesn't mean that i couldn't
make a second pass and and try to learn
something again
um whole pattern and definition
basically is what we're
right so um
yeah and then there are a couple of
other things which i i think are are
sort of uh
wow whole pattern does not appear in my
let's see
it does not appear in my email archive
until 1995.
okay so maybe it was v3 that it was
introduced right because it was right
there was the old literal which was both
hold all and
you know
right and then it was split into two
symbols verbatim which just meant
you know treat this literally
and hold pattern which meant
don't uh you know don't let the thing
evaluate and match against the
unevaluated thing that's my recollection
of the history
okay
why would we have put definition
i bet we had a reason to do that
so let's see if i can find it
um
let's see this is in
now what i'm finding here is stuff which
has those two functions let's see
definition and context unfortunately i'm
mostly just finding lists of functions
it's not really helping very much
um no
it's all browser category lists
yeah
i'm curious if uh and i don't have a v2
book handy but i i'm wondering if i got
one
um
if if maybe this is some hold over from
the literal days that it was
let's take a look we're looking at v2
and we want to know
did attributes uh
you know the one i should look up yeah
um
i think this is this is online another
one but i'm looking at the paper version
because it's easier to pull down
attributes
right so that's probably why
so it was grandfathered over from that
right
and that probably even worked in v1
i see so we just decided because literal
worked we would make whole pattern work
let's see if the attributes worked right
and i'm certainly not suggesting that we
remove the functionality i just think
there are more useful things to document
that um like the uh like the string form
yeah i agree
which is not documented right now
oh well i will tell you something it
wasn't in v1
that was added in v2
that attributes of literal was added in
b2
okay right and and the commit history
doesn't go back to the
it goes back to sort of near the end of
v2 right i think it's the commit history
goes to like 2.1 or 2.2
so
uh so unless that's in your email
archive i don't know how to research the
history of that decision
to put literal into
in into attributes
um
let's take a look i'll just see if i can
pull something up i'm not optimistic
because those are such common words
my gosh
well
i don't know there might be something
here hold on
this is
who knows i mean this is a
this is a piece of mail
oh no that's literal in condition added
10 24 90.
um
hard to tell
that seems like a different thing
[Music]
but when would this have been this would
have been probably oh this is around
1990 this would have been happening
pm cymbal head strips off some who knows
um
well
yeah this seems to be liter you know
very deeply in the pattern matcher and
not so much about the connection to
attributes
okay all right so we don't know but i
agree with you i think we could
de-document it
okay um okay but then so making all of
these like down values work with the
quoted symbol name
but the string symbol name seems
sensible to me
yeah i i think that's both obvious and
uh
you know
and probably i could be wrong because
it's not like i i know the details of
these functions off the top of my head
but i think this would be pretty
straightforward to implement now there's
the okay the single list case seems
pretty obvious
the the nested list case seems not so
clear
right and it does and we're not sort of
explicitly documenting i think implied
means that there may be a an example
what what does implied mean
in um in the first instance it's because
the function's listable
oh okay and information it's implied
because it's listable in sort of one of
its arguments yeah and your audio is
truly terrible
sorry but go ahead yeah
right so yeah so right so right so
attributes is literally listable which
you you know the other guys can't be
right because they take two arguments
and
and
you know uh and and
right the second argument is literally a
list of things so yeah so i think we
probably don't really care but i just
thought i would bring that up i wouldn't
document anything other than the pure
one level list
okay
uh okay now next to string patterns
right so the things that currently like
clear and whatnot they take strings
which are wild cards you know with the
old at which only matches lower case
letters and whatnot
um but they don't support you know
string expression or
uh
which they should right but the point is
that the other things like for example
down values it's going to be confused
because
clear
returns nothing i mean in modern times
it might return a success or something
like that but clear returns null isn't
it
um
yes
uh
yes clear returns null
protect and not protect return the
symbols that they actually modified but
okay okay
but but so but the main point here is
that
how does protect
if protect for example has a wild card
does it always return a list even though
even if there's only a singleton
yes okay fine so so wild card means it's
always going to return a list
right so yeah let me just double check
that i'm not lying but if i say
protective f yeah it returns a list
containing f
and so protect
of quotes f even without a wild card
uh
well i used a symbol f but i presumed
that the string f would behave similarly
yep
okay all right so
the case the point that i'm making is
down values of f would normally just
return the down values list not a list
of the down values list
see what i'm saying so if we make that a
wild card thing we would have
incompatible return types
right and that's why i i
that's why i did not suggest that we add
the
strings to those guys i think the real
questions are things like definition
definition and full definition which
right they format as like
things that you typed in but they're
right they're returning the string they
basically return unevaluated and just
format
but also then i think that they should
yeah allow the wild cards i don't see
why they shouldn't
okay
i would not use wild cards for things
like all those things at the top down to
context exactly uh that that is down to
context yep that's
that's exactly
what my thoughts exactly so unless
somebody disagrees with the two of us i
think
well now what about information what
does information do
um information uh
essentially behaves like names right if
it looks if you give it a string
and i think i think unlike
uh but names is always going to return a
list
right and and so it will return a
oh nick is not in this meeting but i
think it returned i think it returns a
list of of information objects
um but let me double check that
information of f star
oh no it returns uh
right it returns the thing that uh
yeah that guy
right and then you click and you
click right so it's it's still an
information data object but it's an
information data object
that complicated a weird thing i don't
know it didn't i never looked inside
right and the point that the point is
you can extract things right well you
can click on those things to get the
actual information thing printed
and you should be able to also
uh
you know be able to extract things oh
maybe you can't i think that's a small
limitation
but uh
all right but basically what's happening
here is that information
is returning some structured object so
it's not just returning a list or
singleton it's returning some elaborate
thingy
right in both cases so like if you did
percent 48 the the information of plot
of down values
you know that will actually extract
information i guess we did not implement
the the sub values for the multiple
symbol case
um which
seems like an oversight uh you you you
needed uh capitalize the v
okay
okay well i think this seems sensible
anything else we need to discuss about
these yeah i don't think so
yeah
nice to clean up
all right quickly let's
i don't i don't think this is so i'll
tell you what this is but given that
it's after already after five o'clock
i'm not sure we we should be digging
into this so basically there are a few
i'm not saying that there's anything
wrong here but it's just working with
ian on some of the tree documentation
and tree implementation i noticed
they're sort of
differences where like extract
behaves differently than i might expect
but
tree extract behaves differently than i
might expect based on my experience with
extract
which maybe is the correct thing to do
but it's just a little weird and i
thought it would come here and justify
himself here
i mean i could justify the decisions we
made but i agree with etai this is the
longer discussion
okay
you are confident i mean we we discussed
this at length did we know we're not
doing anything like
obviously wrong
but there are some subtle things that
get done with expressions that don't get
done with trees
okay um
yeah like i said this is open discussion
and
you know i i would like to i would like
to give it the the
like i said i don't know that there's
anything wrong but i think it's useful
to go through this and you know you know
i i'm bringing this back with ian's
permission he agrees that there are
things worth
discussing
that you know
can we make sure we actually have
examples next time for this there are
examples if you if you though if you
open up the the bullet points see the
little opener things each one of those
text summaries opens into uh
into related examples so
okay i will make a comment for ian okay
this is as you say too complicated for
us to jump into right now
um commentary ian i was using trees
yesterday
and the thing that i really want is just
a plain i want to have a good way
like i have trees which have come from
expressions and i want to just be able
to have
uh
you know colored nodes and things for
the
different
operators in the middle of the tree and
colored nodes for
the um different leaves and so on i
could not figure out how to do that
how do i do that
are you wanting like a style function
yeah i mean i just want to take a tree
you know i want to take a generic tree
let's say i have let's say i do this so
i say groupings
of um
you know a b
a
f arrow two
okay i got two little trees there okay
and so now i say
expression tree
okay lovely now i want those trees to
not have the explicit a b i just want
dots basically for those uh i i don't
want to explicitly display the the um
those things in the tree
do you understand what i'm saying
so if i say
a different label or do you want to
change the shape of the node
no i want to no i i don't want a label
there i just want the node to be minimal
there so if i say in this
if i say expression tree
of this thing
can i give it something
right
yeah okay but so now if i say
tree element label
arrow
i finally learned how to do this all
arrow none
right
then i get that
which is okay
but what i want to do is i want to color
the f's one color i want to color the
a's and b's different colors and so on
how do i do that
based on the content not on the position
is what you're saying yes based on the
content
okay so then i think we would need
something like tree element label
function that you have proposal
okay which was already
that determines the label based on what
the data is
right you can give patterns for
positions
and and you know and color based like so
you could color all the leaves based on
how do i do that
can't you just say like that uh tree
element style goes to
list underscore
there's no pattern to give you the
leaves
oh there isn't yeah
so i mean if i did why don't you have
minus one
if i do this
hopefully
these options should take arbitrary
position specs
and then you would be able to say like
tree level minus one
am i able to tell it to use oh no i
can't because this is otherwise it would
go to the wrong thing it has to have
not only it has to have both the payload
and the um
it has to give the
tree element position
there otherwise these things will alight
into the same elements
yeah yeah but that's probably what i
have to do i have to turn it into a
graph and then pick out and then do
something which is a pattern on the
vertex names
okay all right i mean it's not the best
thing and i really think that the you
know in handling trees the thing i'm not
happy with is the fact that they keep on
thinking that the elements of these
trees should be independently meaningful
and that's not what i'm doing i'm doing
enumerating gazillions of trees and all
i want is the shape of the tree see what
i'm saying
yep
but i want a little bit more tagging
information because they're like leaves
that are two types and so on
um
all right
anything else we should cover today
nope
okay well thanks much everybody thanks
to folks on the live stream and see you
another time